Good day everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
My name is Paul.
Today I'm going to be talking about
something that has been all the rage
recently,
something called duo lingo.
Now this is a totally free language
learning platform.
It has a online desktop version and also
a smart phone version.
It's something that I haven't gotten
around to trying until just recently
because I've been so busy with other
things,
but everyone's talking about it.
People keep asking me,
hey,
have you tried to do a lingo?
So I had to get on it and see what I
thought of it.
So I started duolingo lingo just a few
days ago.
I started with Esperanto.
Why did they choose Esperanto?
Well,
I wanted to start with a language I've
never studied before just so I could try
out the platform and focus on that.
I'll test out Esperanto and duo lingo at
the same time.
That was my thinking.
So my basic impressions of duo lingo is
that it's a great free resource that you
can use a,
it's excellent,
it's motivating,
it's fun,
but it's not the only thing that you
should use for reasons that I will get
into in a minute.
So let's just have a look and see how it
works.
You can see right here,
this is my profile page that's me over
here,
Paul Jorgensen.
And you can see over here on my language
is Esperanto level six.
Let's look back at this page over here.
The basic theme of duo lingo is
gamification.
They want language learning to be like a
game,
something that can motivate you and keep
you studying every day.
Because one of the biggest problems with
language learning is that people give up
and there are not consistent.
I have a video about consistency.
It's very important.
Consistency is king had.
You really need to study every day if
you want your skills to keep
progressively improving.
So they're trying to solve that problem
of lack of consistency by making it a
game.
So if you look over on the left down
here,
we have an Esperanto skill tree.
They have that for every language.
Of course it starts off with basics.
So you go in here,
this is one skill.
Then you have a few lessons for each
skill and then you move on to the next
one,
to the next one,
and as you move down,
you're achieving targets.
You're getting something called
experience points.
So over here,
like my goal is set at 20 experience
points per day.
If I get that,
then I've met my goal today.
I went on a rampage,
I've got 380 because I wanted to just
get a lot under my belt before talking
about Duolingo.
But if you meet your target,
it's just like a,
you know,
you're patting yourself on the back
thing.
Yay,
I got,
I met my goal for my experience points
for today and you get something called a
streak.
So I'm on a two day streak yesterday.
I surpassed my 20 experience points
today,
surpass by a long shot.
So if you keep up that streak,
then you start to get some other rewards
as well.
The experience points that you get when
you are on a streak.
But also when you finish some of these
skills and when you do some translation
services or when you do some kind of a
time to practice,
you get these experience points and
they're basically just a way,
a symbolic way to motivate you.
But there are these other reports called
lean gods I've been got from,
it gets whatever you call them and you
get these when you finish a new skill
for the first time.
And also when you've leveled up to a new
level,
then you get a certain number of
[inaudible].
So if you level up to level four for
example,
you'll get four ling got sore.
If you pass level 10 then you'll get 10
lingo.
It's like that.
And then when you finish a new skill and
you get,
I forget how many exactly,
you get to mingle or something and they
build up.
So when you get enough of this lingo I
these little jewel things,
then you can go to the link.
Got Store and you can buy some neat
stuff with them.
Now these are mostly just for the
purpose of gamification and nothing
useful.
You can't order like the tee shirt or
whatever as far as I know,
but you can do stuff like this,
a strict freeze.
So if you need to take a day off and you
don't want to end your streak,
then you can buy a streak freeze for
four 10 link dots.
Or here's a little gambling,
a fun activity,
double or nothing.
You can bet five lane guts and maybe
you'll,
you'll get 10 link God's back if you
maintain a seven day streak.
So it's just basically wagering on your
own ability to maintain your streets.
So it's just kind of a fun way to make
use of this lingo lights.
Another couple of things.
You can take a time to practice so you
can see how well you're doing.
That costs 10 lingo.
You can take a quiz,
a progress quiz,
and that costs 25 lingo.
So all these things that you can buy
with those lingo that you earned.
There were also a couple of additional
items available on the smartphone only
and you can buy some special clothing
for the duo mascot,
a mascot and duos an hour and you can
buy some clothing for him.
So when he appears on your screen to
congratulate you on a job well done,
he'll appear in his new updated closing.
That's another reward you can buy with
your lingo.
So again,
it's just a fun thing to motivate you.
Having things like experience points and
rewards for your successes,
that's something that will appeal to a
lot of people who are into role playing
games or video games,
that kind of thing.
And it's really expanding language,
learning into off all new audience.
And I think that that's really great.
Another element of duo lingo that helps
motivate you in a game like way is that
you can connect with your friends and
you can follow each other's progress.
So you can see how much they've done
today,
how many experience points they've
gotten today.
And if you've got more than you can call
them out on that and you can challenge
them or you can make bets with each
other,
that kind of thing.
So it's really good just to keep each
other accountable.
Some people don't need that personally.
I don't really need that kind of
accountability,
but some people really do.
And for them it's great.
Okay.
So getting into the actual language
taught and the learning method,
I really liked the order of the language
that they introduced.
It's a very logical,
and it starts from the beginning and
progress into the more advanced material
starts with very basic sentence
structures,
like a basic vocabulary,
like uh,
the translation for men.
Okay.
Veto,
right.
So that's correct.
Yes.
I know what's correct.
So continue me and the STSV.
I am not you.
That's what that means.
I am not used to put that in.
Check it.
Get lost a CC cleaner.
Don't need you.
Right.
So that's correct.
Let's continue.
LACMA,
marbles,
and that means the boy.
So it's just basic vocabulary and it's
just basic sentence structures.
Like,
I am you,
I am not you.
I am a boy.
I am a man starts with very simple
stuff.
Just a equals b sentences.
Yes.
Okay,
go back.
Um,
and then it progressively gets more of
advanced start building up some more
basic grammar and some basic vocabulary.
The accusative,
plurals possessive,
uh,
animal vocabulary,
country vocabulary.
So it's very basic stuff.
But as you get down here,
then you get more into the advanced
grammar,
more events,
topics,
health,
travel,
education.
So it,
it looks quite good.
I haven't gotten through all of it yet,
but I'm a third of the way through or
something.
And I think the order that they teach
the language and it's quite good,
the selection of vocabulary is quite
good.
And the sentence,
it gets you to produce our,
well,
not totally natural there.
They're basic and they are the sentences
you should be learning at this level.
I think.
So let's go into another skill that I
was doing more recently.
We'll just kind of,
I'll redo it and walk through it with
you.
So this one Bonai Pat Toi have us long
Gyne Tago in.
So that means I know what it means.
Literally.
I don't know what they're trying to say,
but I mean it's good fathers have long
days.
What the heck does that mean?
I'm not quite sure,
but that's what it says.
So when you are looking at a sentence
like this,
sometimes you have to translate it and
sometimes from Esperanto into English,
sometimes English into Esperanto.
Sometimes it just asks you to translate
a word or um,
just look for vocabulary matching,
that kind of thing.
But under each,
each point there's a link here.
You can discuss the sentence with your
peers.
You can look down here and discuss and
ask questions about the sentence.
Like this one,
people are saying,
what does this mean though?
Cause they don't know what the message
of that sentence is.
What the community interactions kind of
neat gives you a chance to discuss
things and get further clarification if
you need it.
Vito Estos Bella.
Okay.
So that means,
oh man is handsome.
So that's another very basic sentence.
Of course
oil,
it's the plural form,
right?
Veto a with the J at the end.
If your toy men are handsome.
So it gives you the correction down here
at one thing I don't like is that it
doesn't give you a chance to enter the
correct sentence if you get something
wrong.
There's actually,
you know,
psychological reasons behind this that
you should have a chance to correct the
mistake.
So for me as a teacher,
when I'm teaching my students,
if they make a mistake,
I always have to give them a chance to
correct themselves.
I don't want to leave them hanging.
It leaves a kind of open loop where they
feel like they've failed and they
haven't actually fixed the problem.
So it just,
it creates a kind of lingering
dissatisfaction.
I don't like that.
I would prefer if they change so that
you could enter the correct sentence
right here after you have gotten it
wrong.
That's just a psychological thing and
educational concept that I think is
important.
I hope they can fix that in the future.
But anyway,
moving on,
Julep has sona,
it's dust.
Malibu owner is the person in bed.
That's what it means.
Is the person bad check it being yes.
So you can see as you get them correct.
Then this progress bar starts moving
towards your goal at the end here.
And when you reach this area,
then that means you're finished the
skill.
But the exercises are slightly different
on the smartphone application.
It's not always entering them in a box.
Sometimes they have a bunch of tabs with
words on them and you can arrange those
words.
So you're practicing the syntax.
Some of the smartphone exercises are a
little better than the online version.
Um,
but both of them are good.
You can do both.
Now,
one thing that you might notice is that
it's all just sentence translation.
You're given a sentence and you have to
translate it or you're given a phrase
and you have to translate it or you have
to just complete a sentence with a word
like that.
That duo lingo is great for learning the
basic sentence structure of a language
and the basic vocabulary of a language
basically for making sentences.
It's similar to something like the
Michelle Thomas Method,
which I think is useful,
but it's kind of limited because you
just learn how to translate into your
target language basically.
So it's not really giving you the
interactive skills,
it's not teaching you the discourse
skills that you need to be able to
communicate in a real context,
so that's its main weakness,
but it is good for teaching you how to
make sentences.
Now,
another weakness that I think is
actually quite critical as that duo
lingo can't really effectively be used
offline.
I was in Philippines just this week and
in Philippines they don't have reliable
internet.
With your data connection with your
smartphone or on even on your laptop at
home,
often there's an inconsistent wifi
connection,
so it made it really hard and almost
almost pointless to use duo lingo when I
was out on the go,
especially with my data on my smartphone
because you just walk 10 steps and
you're out of range or you,
you turn a corner and you're out of
range,
you sit in a coffee shop and you're out
of range.
So I would have to sit there and wait to
know if my answer was correct or I would
know it was correct,
but I would have to wait for the next
question to load until I got into range
and just made it basically too much
trouble to even bother.
So I really didn't bother with duo lingo
when I was in Philippines this week.
So that's just one thing that I think
they have to tackle,
especially if they want dual lingo to be
a truly global service.
They're going to have to make it so that
you can do it offline.
Like you can download some of the levels
or you can download a certain number of
skills,
do them offline,
and then you can upload your progress
once you get in range of Wifi or data.
I think that's really important.
They really need to do that.
I know that some other applications do
do that,
so I hope duo lingo gets on top of it.
That will be really useful for people
like me who travel and really useful for
people who are in developing countries
or places where there's inconsistent
connection.
But in conclusion,
I think duolingo was an excellent free
resource,
especially because it's free.
I just think that that's really cool
that you can get the service for free
and then maybe an exchange volunteer,
you're a translation services just as a
gift back to them.
I think that that's a really cool way to
do it.
Using crowdsourcing in exchange for some
kind of free service.
I think that's awesome and it just shows
where we are in 2015 it's an awesome
online economy as far as I'm concerned.
So I think if duo lingo balances the
skills taught a little better,
if it gives you more opportunity to do
some kind of simulated interaction,
like some question and answer exercises
and that kind of thing,
it gives you a little more listening
practice,
then it will become even more useful.
So I hope they keep expanding the
features include some things like that,
but even as it stands,
it's great.
It's a fun way to just practice on the
go.
It's a fun way to dabble in a new
language a little bit.
If you want to see what it's like,
it's free.
It's easy to start.
It's fun because of the game of vacation
features.
So I think Duolingo is on the right
track and they're creating something
pretty awesome.
So I hope you try it out.
Thank you for tuning into length focus.
This is Paul.
Have a good nights.
See Ya all over the world.
There are people who speak closely
related forms of communication.
Sometimes they are called different
languages.
Sometimes they are called dialects of
one language.
So how do we decide which one they are?
Sometimes there's some disagreement
about which one a particular form of
communication is.
Is it a dialect or is it a separate
language?
Putting them off into the future after
you finish achieving this current goal
right now,
for example,
getting really good at French in the
future.
Beyond that,
you can see the next goal in front of
you,
which is to start learning Spanish or
whatever your language of interest.
Yes.